six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's try let's try the
eight five zero area area code caller
from eight five zero who's this hey hey
we can barely hear you speak up as much
as you can in can you hear me now yeah
that's much better
hi this is Wayne from Pensacola and I'm
a big fan of yours but I have a problem
with your ICO interviews it feels like
you don't necessarily know how to
critique these concepts and you've had
some ridiculous people on and I don't I
don't feel like you've given enough
pushback okay yeah fair point I'll take
it under advisement I mean listen we've
talked about the ICO interviews and
basically you know my I've been super
upfront about everything that's going on
which is we you know over the last year
and a half we've had a bunch of funding
crises including YouTube D monetization
we had a patreon calamity as a result of
a horrible policy change they made and
then retracted we had our Amazon
affiliate link completely taken away so
what we've managed to do which i think
is actually great in a way for the
broadcast show is we can offset or
subsidize some of that lost revenue with
ICO and cryptocurrency related content
that's only going on YouTube so like it
doesn't take up any of the space of the
broadcast radio show doesn't take up any
of the space of the podcast or the
broadcast TV show if you just don't care
about icos or cryptocurrency since it's
only on youtube you just skip over it
but it's helping to offset some of that
lost revenue without impacting the
experience of the broadcast show so you
know it's it's really been working quite
well for us quite frankly well I
actually am interested in cryptocurrency
and I SEOs
gotcha but the ones that you have
covered like the worldwide Internet ones
they're just tacking an ICO on top of
something that has nothing to do with
cryptocurrency just to sell it to people
who don't understand yeah I don't think
that's different than I mean any company
going public doesn't need to go public
in this
same way that you know not all CEOs need
to ICO I think it's a fair criticism
though I mean I think I'm not I'm
listening to what you're saying and I
think it's a fair critique all right
well thank you all right thank you
appreciate the call hey listen this is
what it's all about it's about the
battle of ideas right and that's we're
engaging in that battle of ideas okay
that's all the time we have apologies to
everybody we didn't get to I know
there's a dozen or so people still
holding but we will take calls again
just not until next week